um if you actually knew how hard it was
going to be you just would not do it
it's one of the great parties or
paradoxes
so you guys had
i remember visiting the factory in the
gigafactory at that time period
you literally had executives from the
corporate office on the line delivering
cars interact i mean literally people
who were in accounting
were there delivering model 3s to
customers just to keep the company
solvent i mean the esprit de corpses was
just palatable and uh you know i just
think the world
you probably don't hear this enough but
i think the world does thank you
ultimately
for the massive sacrifice it took to to
make
the world pivot to electric and it's
it's so clear
i think and i'm curious your thoughts
that now that tesla has done this and
succeeded
um it is now inevitable that the ice
engine will be retired and and we will
be 100 electric in the next decade two
or three what are your thoughts on that
uh 100 percent agree i mean with the
we've passed the the threshold here the
tipping point or whatever analogy you
want to use you know there's no um
there's no going back and
you know there'll there'll still be
bumps along the way i mean it's it's
sobering to realize remember you know
what a small percent of the fleet is
still electrified i mean we're still
you know broadly in single digit
percents maybe approaching 10 you know
depending on which region
but um you know we've got a long way to
go still but you know it's clear now to
every major you know auto company
maybe borrow a few holdouts but
um you know they people realize this is
the future and where it's headed
um and it's it's really cool you know
because that was actually one of the the
main
missions of the team at tesla in the
earliest days was you know
even despite how hard it was and you
know maybe we'd fail trying but you know
damn the torpedoes we were going to try
and you know convince the world that
this was the future and accelerate it as
much as we could
and um
you know having that shared mission and
that sense of purpose you know made it
possible i'd say to get through the the
production hell and uh you know keep
everyone
engaged and aligned and create that you
know
that that spirit that you felt uh norway
75
of new passenger car sales in 2020 are
electric it's amazing
i mean they heavily subsidize it they're
incenting but it just shows what this
combination of excellence from tesla and
the product combined with a country that
takes it seriously and by the way norway
has the biggest oil reserves and largest
largest sovereign wealth fund in the
world people don't know that but their
offshore oil is unbelievable
and
it's quite paradoxical that norway is 75
new car ev
and they have the largest reserves of
oil let's just say something about
you know what they're doing domestically
versus what's there if tesla and we'll
go over to redwood materials next
if tesla had failed
what would the state of evs be today
in terms of uh you know let's say you
failed at the model s you know time
period just model s never got delivered
model s doesn't get delivered where are
we at in the world with ev production
well
i mean personally i think the technology
is so compelling that it
it's going it was going to happen at
some point no matter what
um i don't think it would have happened
as fast and i think you know we may
still be
you know bumbling along if tesla had had
failed as you said somewhere in one of
those production ramps s or even three
um you know i just think it would have
taken much longer and and the world
wouldn't be as far along as we are now
and we'd have to do the electric truck
do you think they would be doing it now
or they would do it 10 20 years from now
hard to predict i you know i i i'm
pretty sure it would have been later and
i'm gonna put it at closer to two
decades than one you know it it's and
that really matters you know this stuff
i mean we can't go fast enough in terms
of decarbonizing the world it's
terrifying you know to realize you know
how
how screwed up we are and how far we
still have to go
so
you know that that acceleration and that
you know pulling ahead of you know other
companies launching this is really
really important to the world
uh if extreme weather
no matter how you look at it the the
extreme weather we're seeing
is um
you know
it's it's getting worse i think seven of
the eight fires we had in the last year
are the other record fires uh in
california history so
this is in a very acute situation even
with the massive progress we're making
but you know founders plus technology
can change the world and you did so
we're thankful for that tell us uh about
redwood materials which you started in
2019
yeah redwood materials so um you know i
started this you know to kind of look
ahead at you know some of the issues and
infrastructure and materials supply
chain
uh problems that were coming at us you
know as the whole fleet electrifies
so
you know first off i i love being an
entrepreneur i love building things i
love you know building teams and
companies and projects um
and you know i really believe strongly
in the ability of you know small teams
to have big you know leveraged impacts
on on the future and you know we just
talked about that at tesla of course
but you know what i saw that wasn't
getting addressed i thought fast enough
was um first off looking at the end of
life for ev batteries
you know it seems like a small issue and
it seems far in the future and not
something to worry about but
it is a
substantial scale problem and it's going
to take us quite a few years to get
ready at scale um
you know to fully
de-manufacture all of these batteries uh
and i think it's it's the the challenge
of reaching scale and economies of scale
around that
uh that a lot of people forget
and the other thing for me is is sort of
imagining where this this all ends up
and you know
pretty bullish that the whole fleet is
going to electrify all the cars on the
planet will be electric
and you know once you do that you know
all of those materials that make up
those cars
are going to be in a closed loop
ecosystem you know they don't go away
they're in the car for the life of the
car and you know that combined industry
is bigger than all of the mining that
feeds it it's it's you know bigger than
the existing kind of you know parts
industries that supply it and it doesn't
exist today
so to me it's sort of seeing this
massive industry that that is going to
be created it's a certainty
and also seeing nothing happening yet
and it not existing that that to me was
part of the really compelling reason to
jump into redwood
if your bank charges outrageous fees you
need a bank account that's built for
small business and that bank account is
novos free business banking novo novo is
built from the ground up to be
powerfully simple and free money
magazine called it the best business
checking account of 2021 and with novo
there are no minimum balances no
transaction limits and no hidden fees so
sign up for free in under 10 minutes at
banknovo.com twist and then they're
going to mail you a novo debit card and
get you free atm use that's right you'll
be able to use the atms for free and
novo makes banking easy and secure you
can manage your account in novos
customizable apps with built-in
accounting and invoicing plus you can
tag each transaction and upload your
receipts and keep everything nice and
tidy so that when you go into due
diligence as a startup or you have a
board meeting everything's tight and
tight is right when it comes to your
books don't screw up your future funding
rounds by not having good books novo
integrates with most leading business
tools and services like stripe shopify
quickbooks and more and they do that all
for free plus novo offers over five
thousand dollars in perks and discounts
just for signing up so get your free
business banking account in just 10
minutes at banknovo.com
twist go to banknovo.com
twist to sign up for free right now and
get a free copy of novo small business
starter guide once again banknova.com